اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مجددا في النافذه
للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على
قطاع غزه نستضيف فيها دائما اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اهلا
بك معنا قبل ان نتحدث للواء فايز نذهب الى
سلام خضر وابرز التطورات الميدانيه سلام
شكرا عبد السلام اذا هناك تطورات متسارعه
في اكثر من منطقه في قطاع غزه من القتال
الدائر بين القوات الاسرائيليه وكتائب
القسام وبقيه فصائل المقاومه
الفلسطينيه اليوم هناك تركز كبير جدا
للمعارك في محيط مخيم البريج بوسط قطاع
غزه اسرائيل قالت انها توسع عملياتها
وتحاول السيطره بشكل كامل على مخيم البريج
حتى الان المعلومات الميدانيه الموثقه
تفيد بان القوات الاسرائيليه ما زالت
تهاجم بريج دون ان تتمكن من الدخول اليه
هناك مقاومه قويه وشديده جدا من كتائب
القسام تحديدا نفذت عده عمليات ادت الى
تراجع القوات الاسرائيليه من المناطق
المحاذيه تماما لمخيم البريش تراجعت
القوات الاسرائيليه الى الخلف بعدما وقعت
في حقل الغام كبير نصبتها له كتائب القسام
ونجحت باستدراج قوه اسرائيليه واوقعت
خسائر وقتلى وجرحى دفع بهذه القوات الى
التراجع الى الخلف عندما حدث هذا الامر
بطبيعه الحال
كما اعلن اليوم من مخيم البريش تعرض
لغارات عنيفه اسرائيليه مخيم البريج وايضا
المناطق المحيطه به في محاوله لتامين
بدايه انسحاب القوات وتراجع القوات لا
نقول انسحاب تراجعت القوات ولم تتمكن من
التموضع عند مداخل مخيم البريج نتيجه
المقاومه قصف الطيران اتى لتامين هذا
التراجع وايضا في محاوله لالحاق خسائر
لالحاق خسائر بكتائب القسام والفصائل
المقاومه التي تقاتل في البريج هذه منطقه
منطقه قتال محتم محتدم جدا علما ان اقصى
نقطه تبعد من مخيم البريج عن السياج
الحدودي لا تزيد على كيلومتر ونصف فاذا
نحن تقريبا نتحدث عن عن منطقه اشتباك لا
تزيد مساحتها على كيلو ونصف كيل متر مربع
هذه
في وسط قطاع غزه بالانتقال الى جنوب
القطاع المزيد من التطورات اليوم التي
اعلنت عنها اسرائيل على اكثر من مستوى
ايضا اليوم هناك لواء اسرائيلي جديد انضم
الى الالويه التي تقاتل في قطاع غزه في
المنطقه الجنوبيه هناك بات لدينا سته
الويه اسرائيليه سبعه بل سبعه الويه
اسرائيليه تقاتل في منطقه الجنوب وتحديدا
خان يونس وخزاعه خان يونس ما تزال
الاشتباكات فيها مستمره لم تدخل القوات
الاسرائيليه الى خان يونس على الاطلاق حتى
هذه اللحظه لا تزال تهاجم من اكثر من محور
خاصه من المحطه و من شارع خمسه وبحسب
المعلومات ان هذه القوات الاسرائيليه التي
تتقدم من الشرق لم تصل للمخيم التي تدخل
من عفوا التي تدخل من الشمال لم تصل الى
حدود المخيم التي تدخل من الشرق لم تصل
بعد الى خط صلاح الدين هذا هو خط صلاح
الدين الذي يربط اقصى شمال القطاع باقصى
جنوبه القوات الاسرائيليه لم تتخطى بعد
صلاح الدين وبالتالي خان يونس المدينه لا
تزال بعيده عن دخول القوات الاسرائيليه
اليها ولكن ما شهده اليوم ايضا الجنوب هو
اي اشتباكات عنيفه جدا في منطقه خزاعه
منطقه خزاعه منطقه حدوديه لا تبعد كثيرا
عن السياج الحدودي اشتباكات قويه وعنيفه
واستهداف من كتائب المقاومه من القسام ومن
سرايا القدس للقوات الاسرائيليه في الجنوب
تعمد القوات
الاسرائيليه او تستخدم القوات الاسرائيليه
اسلوب الكر والفر لا تتمركز ولا تتموضع في
مكان واحد نظرا لكثافه ال الهجمات التي
تشنها المقاومه نختم فقط ان الشمال لا
يزال مشتعلا ونحن في اليوم ال84 للحرب
الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه وفي ال يعني
العمليه البريه منذ شهرين مستمره ل لا
تزال الاشتباكات في التفاح وفي حي الدرج
وعند اطراف الشيخ رضوان التي تراجعت عنه
القوات الاسرائيليه لا تزال هذه
الاشتباكات مستمره الشجاعيه اليوم
المعلومات تقول بان القوات الاسرائيليه لم
تعد بداخل الشجاعيه هي تتمركز عند نقطه
واحده او نقطتين خارج حدود شارع الشجاعيه
طبعا عبد السلام هذه ابرز التطورات هناك
تطورات عسكريه نوعيه ميدانيا اعتقد سيتم
مناقشتها مع الدويري كثير من هذه
المعلومات تحتاج الى تفكيك شكرا جزيلا لك
سلام خضر وعن تفكيك المشهد الميداني معك
سياده اللواء نبدا من البريج وما الذي حدث
ما التكتيك الذي تستخدمه قوات المقاومه
الفلسطينيه لمنع جيش الاحتلال من التوغل
اكثر يعني في البدايه بدات معركه خان يونس
قبل اسابيع من بدء معركه
البريج ولكنها لم تحقق اي
انجاز يمكن ان يفضي الى تطوير
العمليات دخلت من كسفين القراره اتجاه
المطاحن ابراج
الحمد لوصولا الى منطقه المواصي جوش قطيف
ولكنها هذه كاح حاطه لم تحق اي نتيجه
ميدانيه في المقابل في المنطقه الشرقيه
دفعت بزخم قوات كبير وصل قبل 48 ساعه الى
خمسه الويه
كذلك فشلت في تحقيق وذكرت بانها لم تصل
الى الى فقط الى شارع صلاح الدين بقيت
عالقه في
المنطقه قبل ثلاثه ايام من اجل ان يحقق
انجاز هكذا اقرا من اجل ان يحقق انجا جاز
في
منطقه شرق خان يونس بنس هيلله الزن عبسان
الكبيره دفع بفرقه 36 المدرعه باتجاه
البريج والنصيرات من اجل لانه بعض
القراءات
الاسرائيليه هم يعرفوا ان الدفاع على اساس
مناطقي جغرافي ولكن عندما تصبح هناك خطوره
او ارتباك في جيش الاحتلال يحاول ان يجد
مقاربه اخرى فكان من اعتقاده ان هذه
الكتائب تتحرك تحت الارض من نقطه الى اخرى
وبالتالي اذا ما تم مهاجمه البريج
والنصيرات س ستجبر كتائب القسام على وبقيه
الفصاله على سحب جزء من هذه القوات
لمواجهه الخطر الجديد فشلت المحاوله
الاولى لانها كانت تسعى للحركه على شارع
صلاح الدين في اليوم التالي تحولت العمليه
وبدات مهاجمه البريج من ثلاثه اتجاهات من
الشمال ومن الشرق ومن الجنوب لان معظمها
ارض زراعيه كانت مصائد الامس وتم تدمير 19
اليه في هذا اليوم صدر بيان جديد انه خلال
ال 48 ساعه ارتفع الرقم الى 72
اليه فبالاسحار تفاع عدد الاليات في وقت
زمن ضراوه القتال ضراوه القتال اداره
اداره المعركه الدفاعيه صوره ناجحه وفاعله
جدا ماذا فعلت بعد ه بعد ان لم تستطع ان
تحقق شيء في منطقه البريج وان المقاربه
البريج سيارات لم لم تؤت ا كلها من اجل
فتح ثغره في الجدار الدفاعي او المنطقه
الدفاعيه في منطقه بني سهيلا وما حولها
دفع بالامس بلواء رقم سته ام لم
يؤتي لم يقدم اي نتيجه في هذا اليوم دفع
باللواء مظليين لانه المعركه لاحظ معظمها
تدمير اليات ومعدات قتال لماذا لانه القوه
الرئيسيه التي دخلت هي اما قوات مشاءلله
او دبابات هنا كانه اكتشف
ان ازدياد الخسائر في المعدات وبال
الافراد كانه هناك عجز في المشاه التي يجب
ان تؤمن هذه القوات فدفع لواء سابع وهو
لواء المظليين من اجل ان يحقق الامن
النسبي للاليات المتقدمه اذا اردنا ان
نتحدث عن التطور الكبير فيما يتعلق بتفجير
حقل الغام كيف يمكن ان يساهم مثل هذا
النوع من التكتيكات في ردع قوات الاحتلال
من التوغل الان هذه للمره الثانيه تحدث
يعني حدث قبل ذلك والان يتم هذه محاكاه
قريبه هذا هذا محاكاه هو ماذا يجري يتم
قرا را ارض المعركه ما هي الاماكن المغريه
لقوات العدو من اجل لتكون هي الاكثر
ملائمه من وجهه نظر العدو للاستخدام هنا
ما ماذا يحصل يتم تحضير العديد من الحشوات
بانواع مختلفه بمسميات مختلفه باليه تفجير
مختلفه وهذه تبقى موجوده ومعده سلفا وتبقى
في مكانها مجرد وصول قوات الجيش الاحتلال
يتم تفجيرها وجميعها تفجر عن بعد وبالتالي
المسميات هي ترتبط بنوعيه واليه التفجير
وطبعا اما ان تفجر كهربائيا بصوره مجمعه
او ان تفجر كهربائيا بصوره مفرده او
مزدوجه او يمكن ان تفجر بطريقه الكورتكس
وهي معروفه لجماعات الذين يخدموا في سلاح
الهندسه في اي جيش في العالم هنا تكون
النتيجه ضربه ناجحه وقويه خاصه اذا ما كان
توزيع هذه الحشوات والمسافات البينيه
بينها تتناسب وطبيعه انفتاح القوات
المعادي ام ما يتعلق
بالاسلحه الجديده مثلا الطائرات التي يتم
استخدامها الان هناك نوع جديد يدخل في
المعركه يتم استخدامه ربما لاول مره اذا
اردنا ان نفهم نوعيه الاسلحه التي يتم
استخدامها في الساعات الاخيره والايام
الاخيره من قبل المقاوم الان هناك تركيز
على استخدام الطائرات العموديه الاباتشي
لانه قد تقدم الكثير الطائره تحمل 16
صاروخ هذا في البعد القتالي وبالتالي كان
هناك طلب في الاسبوع الماضي بتعزيز اضافي
الان هذه سكاي لارك 2 هي طائره استطلاع
مزوده بتقنيه عاليه جدا تسير لمسافه 60 م
ويمكن وتطير على ارتفاع يصل الى 15000 قدم
هذه مزوده بكاميرات حساسه ذات تقنيه
متطوره جدا وتقدم بث مباشر عن طبيعه الارض
للقوات لجيش الاحتلال المتقدمه اي بمعنى
اخر كيف تم
اسقاطها الان لم يحددوا الوسيله اذا كانت
على ارتفاع منخفض يمكن اسقاطها
بالاسلحه المتوسطه واذا كانت اعلى يمكن
استخدام
صواريخ سام 18 كما حدث في اسقاط الطائره
السابقه كانت اشاره ان هنا ان استخدمت
صواريخ ضد الجو في اسقاطها لكن خطورتها
هذه تقد معلومات مومنت باي مت للقوات
المتقدمه عن طبيعه ارض المعركه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك اللواء فايز الدويري المحلل
الاستراتيجي والخبير العسكري على كل ما
تفضلت به